[Musique]
vous
où
bon sans farine et chasse
commerciale de
un scientifique une chasse aux phoques
gris
et pas facile
toujours une certaine excitation
oui
une belle sortie de chasse au fait que
c'est
avant de retrouver les flics on a
l'habitude avant
[Musique]
au score sur 9 10 ans
valide si j'allais blanc que là puis on
a des systèmes de communication fait que
pour en ligne et l'équipe
l'équipe de collecteur
ouest jean claude
s'il est plus d'un bon mauvais
finisseur problème
sur la côte possibilité de voler si je
peux leur échapper au sirop
on attend vraiment les rangs des
nouveaux prix si ici
comme l'autre lui s'il en face de moules
m'amuse pas tirer oui je pourrais là bas
mais leur échappe repos vivre et de
sourire pour le folk convié ma visite au
télescope il faut que s'ouvre mardi a
placé pour qu'on puisse les avoir
comme une hyène en janvier
il a à midi et notre tour incendie
avec moi je suis dans le bateau puis je
suis fan est donné par exemple le temps
entre le moment où le phoque est tirée
depuis le temps où il va être récupérés
ou l'achat de paris pour récupérer une
faute la distance entre le tireur
la chaloupe notre sens entre les tireurs
que le phoque
ces genres de choses que nous on regarde
pour être sûr que c'est une chose qui se
passe sans cruauté puis en accord avec
les principes de bien-être animal
je sais pas une chose qui crurent
remporté hier
c'est absolument faux pire qu'elle ait
tiré un orignal à l'étirer instar des
foyers manqué le premier coup on va on
va sereinement l'on veut l'abattre c est
vraiment la même chose même principe
tu leur avoir passé du temps des
cailloux bien les lieux cailloux violent
que ça sent bon la carabine ou là où la
gâter on n'est pas ici pour faire
souffrir un animal ou comme ce soir on
est ici pour récolter de la viande
après
des combats avec la chasse au phoque
avec dieu prise on peut pas se permettre
que monsieur madame tout le monde vient
ici avec aucune supervision si tu veux
faire la chasse aux phoques gris
oublions folle du groenland faut que tu
aies des coûts ce qu'on appelle la
chasse d'abattage en trois étapes après
ça j'ai supervisé pendant douze ans avec
un chasseur professionnel aujourd'hui
vous demain n'importe quel bon zoom peut
s'acheter un arme à feu madrid de
contrôle des armes à feu quand même très
cela n'est dieu semaine après pas la
chasse elle rien à la crise au chevreuil
a le haut ou maras et un monde où
différence avec la tête alors doit
on veut pas que n'importe qui fasse
n'importe où sur la glace ou bien ici
avec de l'eau chez à coups d'armes à feu
sur un animal forêt sud leur échapper
juste pour vous donner une idée avec les
vend aujourd'hui entière juste un côté
de lille parce que d'un autre côté ou
pour annaba bas on a une chance sur van
driessche ap on tire même pas parler
c'est chasselas est vraiment bien
encadré
[Musique]
oui
bah ya beaucoup de phoques je pense que
c'est la nourriture pour tous en amène
beaucoup
yann envoyé à sûr mais pas loin des 5
600 d'après ce que j'ai pu voir
la première fois je mesure les place à
de gros la pression commence un morceau
de muscles
un morceau de peau et de grands qui
après ça je l'avais cherché tout le
système digestif apporter de l'oesophage
jusqu'au au rectum
bah c'est le christ nourrit c'est être
contenus stomacaux jusqu'à l'intestin ça
donne une idée de d'un certain laps de
temps où ce qui s'est nourri pu voir de
quoi et
canale sous sol peut y avoir autant de
la morue que du capelan que du lançant
j'ai trouvé jusqu'à 71 à mende en une
année seulement
1 seule fois oui
coli
vous
[Musique]
ce ciel c'est vraiment la carcasse la
carcasse de fond de grille jeunes de six
mois après soro degrés c après ça on
prélève les chiens doivent opposer les
filières
c'est une viande haut de gamme de
renault gagnent pas pour autant ses
valeurs mais critique que nous vaches
que si de la porte et ramon table
énormément de manutention c'est pas
comme du boeuf du porc
gagnon
c'est énormément de travail mais le
produit fini est super beau ça va
tellement d'amis qu'on travaille qu'on
on en est fiers
parce que chaque fois que tu vas parler
un chef cuisinier une nouvelle viande
qui arrive je suis bien marché c'est un
produit du québec comme de raison pour
réseaux c'est un fleuron
c'est pour que sa flore pour nous
servira pour raisons aussi
prétend que d un avenir pas trop
lointain
on va être bon pour approvisionner hôtel
usines comme ici en viande quand on
cuisine fille si à côté pour la pour
l'huile de phoque
rentrez rentrez
à ce récit c'est le coeur de lusine
c'est vraiment ainsi que la
transformation vaut ce faire
le gros est rempli de propriété on parle
d'une quantité d'une qualité d'oméga 3
qui se trouve pas vraiment comprendre
pas un saumon pour faire de l'huile
d'oméga-3 on veut manger le saumon mais
le gros du phoque on mange repos on veut
pas chassé pour chasser on veut chasser
pour la viande on veut chasser pour du
grand on veut chasser pour de la
fourrure on veut chasser pour tout ce
que le phoque doit être capable de nous
apporter donc ça s'inscrit vraiment dans
un cadre écologique je pense que l'on
crée un débouché qui qui qui passe du
folklore mais vraiment vers le
structurer
on n'est pas
les gens viennent au zèle l'été
partout ce que tu avais parlé ils sont
accueillants ils sont gentils
comment quelqu'un devient c'est une
méchante l'hiver tout à coup
mon père était chasseur monteront pas
maison on n'est pas des barbares on les
chasse à je suis fier de ce qu'on a
mais on n'est pas des barbares
l'isle-briand basséen et la laissent des
îles c'est pas tellement gros il ya
quand même une bonne section plage
la vraie place où entreposer plusieurs
milliers de phoques
quelqu'un que jamais à leurs yeux
brillants ils refoulent bout de se
baigner et à des têtes de phoques
partout la plage est bon départ tout ce
que tu vas regardez il ya du phoque à
chaque année il y en a toujours plus
afin que c'est un problème c'est le
garde manger que je cinq autres et ça
m'a jamais rentrer dans la tête qu'on
puisse pour chasser chez nous
ce qu'ils nous appellent le chasser sur
briand b c'est que c'est une réserve
écologique du ministère de
l'environnement il ya interdit la chasse
je comprends pas je comprends juste pas
pourquoi on ne peut pas chasser chez
nous c'est bien boxé une réserve demande
pas d'aller briser la faune et la flore
si les brillants juste avoir accès à la
plage
on veut pas faire disparaître le phoque
gris mines brillant nino d'une pente
jusqu'au pot les espèces
peu importe que ce soit les brillants
que ça soit ailleurs il ya des coteaux
que des jeux établi
si on les dépose pas il devra pas un
problème ses calculs en conséquence que
la population capable de prendre le taux
de mortalité là
c'est notre source à nous ici au québec
les chassa attend juste le goût pour y
aller vite tout le monde veut faire
c'est de la bonne manière tout le monde
est prêt à faire des efforts c'est
important c'est ça qui va décoller
l'industrie aux labs vient de briand
c'est une ressource qui va dès lors
chaque année qu'il faut pour être
prélevés pas du monde ici pour
l'industrie ozil
[Musique]
il faut être ici pour vraiment
comprendre que ce qui se passe
quand on s'est rendu compte que les
populations froid qui était très
important que ça pouvait même invisible
de ce côté là
on a tout avantage en tant qu'industrie
de bien s'occuper de cette chasse la
teinte plus qu'ailleurs la chasse et de
la
fédération mais on a toujours faisceau
est aussi que les bains sous sud
l'écosystème du golfe saint-laurent qui
est très fragile
[Musique]
accepter ce que là maintenant c'est tout
ce qu'on peut pas les prix soient bonnes
ou moins bonnes et on est content pareil
de pouvoir se nourrir et nourrir et
plein de monde parce que veut pas c'est
vendu un peu partout ailleurs tout le
monde en profite
[Musique]
ce soit tout en incombe au père
spirituel parce que c'est tellement
facile de nous faire mal paraître un
chasseur de phoques sur la banquise ou
ou sur la planche mais je pense j'ai de
la fierté ça s'agite
[Musique]
au petit guy autre chose que ça c'est
non
[Musique]